so bleeding-edge is a new game developed
by Ninja Theory the same company
responsible for hell-blade send away
sacrifice it's not the same group of
people that made it but it is the same
company this time they wanted to do a
little bit of a spin on some games and
make a cartoony for view for team
brawler known as bleeding edge I can't
show any gameplay yet during the Alpha
because currently I will get a copyright
strike on my video if I do that and out
of respect for the devs I don't want to
do that and have them grow through all
that trouble and then of course we get a
copyright strike so eventually when they
do allow people to show off the gameplay
from the Alpha or if it happens to be in
beta
I will definitely show that to you guys
as much as I can but as for the little
bit of the story as we know it's set in
the year 2050 5 I believe and it looks
like some sort of game show because
these characters don't really die they
just disintegrate and I've read some
numerous character bios about this
skeleton key I have no [ __ ] clue what
this is but we may know closer to the
launch about the story of that and what
that even means but so far in the Alpha
we have two maps and ten characters I
can show the characters on screen
because it is available on their website
and they are part of three classes
assassins supports and heavies for the
melee assassins you have nidhogg and
daemon for the rains you have Maeve and
gizmo and don't you even think about it
but if she's 17 we have one melee
support who is Miko and two ranged who
are gonna be zero cool and cool vay and
all three of the heavies are going to be
melee and those are makuu to el Bastardo
and Buttercup I'm not gonna be going
super in-depth on all these characters
that's gonna be saved later for the
Alpha gameplay when I can actually show
it because I'd rather not talk about
every one of their [ __ ] abilities
make this a 30 minute video because one
none of you even care to begin with
surprised you even made it this far into
the video and - it doesn't really sit
right in my stomach making these types
of videos where I talk about the
characters abilities but not actually
show them because it doesn't really give
that visual interpretation so we're
gonna wait until I can actually show the
gameplay and then we could talk about
the characters more in depth maybe in a
guide eventually as for gameplay I told
you it was super big on team player but
I honestly think that it relies way too
much on team play in a one-on-one it's
going to be a super big stalemate and
it's gonna last for like two minutes
with no-one really doing much damage and
in a two-on-one that the person that is
out number two
to die instantly in seconds out of all
the matches that I've played so far I
have not been able to win a two-on-one
with any single character and unless
both opponents were super low on health
and I was actually playing an assassin
I've never actually been able to win a
two-on-one even in this circumstance
with a range character at all and I
think this is a super big issue either
we need to have a mechanic to combat
anti gank or switch up the health and
damage values because as it stands it's
almost impossible to win while you're
outnumbered and that can make some
people angry especially newer players
that just want to test out a new
character I totally understand that this
is a team game and you really should be
sticking with your team but you're not
going to be sticking with your team 100%
of the time so just because you've got a
little lost trying to get to your team
and two people gangbang you you
shouldn't that shouldn't be instant
death for you on top of that there is
this stun effect for all melee
characters when you perform a combo it's
like any other combo in any fighting
game it's your turn to hit and you can
stop these by either evading or doing a
tactical booty if you're on the
receiving end this adds a little bit of
strategy and learning each character and
trying to figure out all their combos
except the problem is that each
character really only has one combo and
it's either spamming the X button three
times or spamming the X button four
times with the occasional character
having the hold X button which can be a
launch move or something like that
it's basically just button mashing so if
two melee characters went at it you can
either dash away from them or use the
tactical ability to stop their combo but
if you're a ranged character all you
have is your dash your guns will not do
[ __ ] so literally in a teamfight the
first character to be killing is a
ranged character or a healer as of right
now if you have three dashes you're
ultimately really good in terms of just
skill rank and top-tier el Bastardo
Damon and nidhogg are some of the
characters that have three dashes I
believe miko does as well although she
doesn't compare as strong as these three
do these three characters both have
three dashes and they are completely
unstoppable each have a melee attack
that can cause the combo stun we talked
about earlier and some have some attacks
that can either launch you in the air
have some type of range ability or have
an AoE ability so basically they have
the whole [ __ ] kit the difference is
that Damon and nidhogg are assassins
Hilda move just slightly quicker than
bastard who is a heavy character but
both still have three down
and that's what really doesn't make a
lot of sense to me is the distribution
of these dashes out of the four
assassins we have in the game nidhogg
Damon gizmo and Maeve nidhogg and Damon
have three dashes and gizmo and Maeve
have two they also belong into the same
group gizmo and Maeve are ranged
assassins and they have two and nidhogg
and Damon are melee assassins and they
have three but why though if anything it
should be closely similar across the
board for the class for the heavies
bastard has three buttercup has one with
but it's a little bit more unique in the
fact that it's more of a sprint and that
it really doesn't run out it doesn't
have a set number so you can kind of use
a little bit or use a lot and makuta
doesn't even have one he has two
different stances I can get it because
it slightly does match up the melee
characters have three and majority of
the ranged have two but I feel like this
is more of a class-by-class basis
another thing I noticed a little bit is
the damage for this game going off many
games with these types of class setups
overwatch paladins any type of game like
that mostly you're gonna be having the
heavy characters which are your slow and
hard-hitting characters but the
assassins are going to be faster and hit
for less while your supports are kind of
varied in what they can do but they most
likely he are gonna be healing a lot
more than doing damage so a damage
really isn't that big of a factor but
they can sometimes hold their own for
the supports though you guys get an A+
100% Cole Vey is incredible he has an
AoE health pool and a debuff spell he's
definitely one of my favorites zero cool
is good too he has a fear he just has a
straight infinite beam of health and
Miko has the ability to actually go on
the offensive and heal her teammates
were also doing damage because every hit
she does she does heal it's super cool
and I love the variety between these
three the problem is that the majority
of the assassins hit too hard and the
heavies don't really hit hard enough
besides a few exceptions Makuta doesn't
really do enough damage despite being a
heavy and Damon hits way too [ __ ]
hard to be an assassin which makes no
sense to me but I feel like I'm
targeting this game too much so on a
positive note I have to admit though the
gameplay it feels super smooth not
clunky not awkward or anything like that
there were a few times when the whole
Lobby would fight in it with lag but
it's an alpha so that'll probably be
addressed pretty quickly anyway but so
that's why I'm not a big issue of it and
when it comes to big team fights the
game
feels great alts going back and forth
abilities falling everywhere it's
absolutely breathtaking
while those characters that I mentioned
before nidhogg damon and el Bastardo
seem really good and a teamfight
anything can happen
it's all done to communication teamwork
making sure you use your abilities
correctly and of course the mods and
boards as well
boards are basically going to be like
your horses from paladin's or your pets
in World of Warcraft the hover board
will make you go faster and to get to
certain points a lot quicker or if you
want to get into a fight quicker that'll
help you and mods are like the cards
from Paragon you can equip three mods at
one time and you can make multiple
builds for multiple scenarios and switch
on the fly these mods can increase
damage to certain abilities increase
health reduce cooldown timers and many
more but you can have gameplay without
game modes and maps and in the Alpha
there was two game modes and two maps as
for the game modes you have a capture
game mode like domination from Call of
Duty where it's three points and you
must capture those points you can also
earn other points for killing opponents
as well and this is called objective
control you start out with no capture
points then after some time all of them
or some of them could light up maybe all
three or maybe only one so each team has
to fight for those lit up control points
and then capture them to get more points
after some time they will disappear this
is what I like to call the breather
phase but there's no points coming out
and it just straight up killing people
and then the points will come back and
then rinse and repeat the first two 6
under points wins the match the next one
is where there's batteries and canisters
scattered throughout the map and you
have to destroy them pick up the
batteries take it to an objective and
deliver them this is called Power Cells
same exact thing applies here one phase
the battery cells are gonna spawn and
then the next some of the objectives are
maybe all the objectives will spawn and
then you have to deposit the batteries
and it's a rinse and repeat until the
game is over which is basically 50
captures of batteries and your team wins
every game mode so far in this beta has
a single pixon meaning you can only have
one character per team and not more than
one so you cannot have two Damon's three
buttercups or four makuu twos you can
only have one per character and then
lastly as for the maps I have to admit I
was pretty surprised my initial thoughts
by looking just at the map were that
this is way too big for the player count
but as I played it more I discovered
that they weren't so bad yet there are
some dead points and there's going to be
no combat at some points
but it's not all the time and honestly
my final critique for this game is that
it really should be a 5v5 and not a 4v
for no real reason behind it maybe I'm
just a sucker for all-out chaos but I
think that it would really help all the
dead combat and make it a lot more
intense and I think if I thought
originally that this game is going to be
a 5v5 mode and I think it could do
wonders adding just that one extra
player into your team oh yeah that's
gonna be my huge impression of the Alpha
test so far for bleeding-edge if you
want to know if I should recommend this
game to you I'm only going to say no
strictly because it's an alpha so just
watching this video and just trying to
decide if you should buy it or not
should not be the decision you should
wait until there's actual gameplay being
or at least and then when the full game
comes out then you make your decision
and then one more quick tip if there's
anything being covered in the alpha or
beta like something happens to come up
like there's a new character or there's
some other new [ __ ] happening maybe they
changed something I'm going to basically
update everybody on the channel about
that just in case but yeah but that guys
like the V if you do enjoy subscriber
for new and take care guys have a great
rest of your day and peace out
[Music]
you
[Music]